labour's policy  to tax the energy companies is supported  by 68 of the public according to polls  you're prepared to be unpopular aren't  you  yes yes i am  what is important to me  is that we grow the british economy  because that is what will ultimately  deliver  higher wages more investment in towns  and cities across the country  that is what will ultimately deliver  more money into people's pockets and it  will also enable us to fund the public  services like the national health  service and in order to get that  economic growth britain has to be  competitive and if we put up taxes if we  have arbitrary taxes on energy companies  if we have high corporation tax we're  not going to get that investment and  growth which will ultimately  damage  damage opportunities in this country and  that's what i'm bothered about what i  care about is are there those jobs there  in the future those high paid jobs  industries like technology industries  like energy that's what is motivating me